l'abolition de l'esclavagé en 1848 vient
également l'instauration du suffrage
universel
bien entendu réservé aux hommes à
l'époque mais du jour au lendemain plus
de 250 mille esclaves de toutes les
colonies françaises d'afrique des
caraïbes et de l'océan indien se
retrouve libre c'est-à-dire électeur et
éligible et les premières élections
organisées après l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
ce sont les élections législatives pour
élire une assemblée nationale
constituante chargée de rédiger la
constitution de la seconde république
est parmi les trois sièges réservés à la
martinique est dévolue à victor petits
frères musulmans
il est né esclave en 1789 placé jeune
enfant chez le maréchal des logis mottin
qui était alors le chef de la
gendarmerie et qu'il emmènera avec lui
en 1806 lors de ces mutations
successives aux états unis puis à paris
et masculine une fois arrivé sur le sol
de la métropole coloniale comme la loi
de l'époque l'exigent est déclarée libre
c'est ainsi qu'il va se mettre quelques
temps plus tard au service de la famille
du général pernety héros des guerres de
napoléon 1er
il ne se mariera plus tard avec la femme
de chambre de la fille du général
pernety avec laquelle il aura deux
filles une demande assez jeune et
l'autre sûrs à l'image du leem qui
viendra plus tard en allant teennick
ouvrir un pensionnat coloniale pour
jeunes filles